welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and morbius stars jared leto as
spider-man villain morbius the living
vampire and sony's ever confusing side
universe to the mcu that michael keaton
tends to wander in and out of like a
sneaky nursing home resident that the
order leads call a runner but now we got
a trailer that i'm sure will get us all
pumped and clearly answer all of our
questions about sony's live-action
spider-verse plant so i'm gonna watch
this trailer react to it and give my
initial thoughts and explanations and
then tomorrow in a separate video i am
going to break down this trailer frame
by frame for all the visual details and
easter eggs that you might have missed
but on to the reaction here we
go
oh sony's got to do their trailer to the
trailer so you know what's coming in the
trailer
do you need a doctor
i am a dog i am a doctor
i should have died years ago
this music
people all over the world have my
disease i'm here
to find a cure
we have to push the boundaries take this
oh cool jim morrison's uh
the doors people are strange
very moody music but there's some deeper
themes that connect with this
what did you do to yourself doctor
how are you what'd you do to yourself
oh horizon okay that's interesting
peter parker works there
not exactly i have increased strength
and speed
some form of fat radar
what else can i do
whoa
whoa
oh oscorp oh interesting
there's something inside of you
what's the hunt
and consume blood
i saw a black cat on there
we haven't had anything this good since
that thing in san francisco
oh that again that what
i should stay in touch
i'd do anything to save a life
i don't know what i'm capable of
you save lives you don't take them
are you here to heal the world
or to destroy it
i like the blood's draining out of the
title that's kind of cool
i
am i
i'm just know
it's dr michael morvious at your circle
okay sure but
why would you say
okay uh got it okay a quick reminder
here dr michael morbius is a medical
genius with a rare blood disorder that
you can see here hampers this movement
but in the comics that also caused poor
michael to look naturally just a bit
beastly but here he just looks like a
hong kong called jared leto so dr
michael morbius experiments with vampire
bat blood serum and electro therapy to
become morbius the living vampire his
various sexy vampiric powers but he is
not technically dead because his powers
did not come from any supernatural
source but rather from science also fun
fact morbius ties in with blade in the
comics when he bites blade he actually
allows blade to then live on with the
powers of a vampire but none of the
weaknesses which is pretty useful thanks
doc now going bald is stressful for the
guys i know going through it sure it's
not the end of the world but much like a
bag of halloween candy or a christmas
stocking you would probably rather have
that sucker be bold and empty two out of
three guys will experience some form of
male pattern baldness by the time
they're 35 but with keeps it's easier
and more affordable to get treatment for
your hair loss and help you keep the
hair that you have keeps offers generic
versions of the only two fda approved
hair loss products out there about a
half the cost of your local pharmacy
though you never have to go to a
doctor's office with keeps you get 24 7
access to a doctor who designs the best
plan for you they offer other helpful
tools and services including a tracking
tool so that you can monitor your
progress find out why keep says more 5
star reviews than any of its competitors
and nearly 100 000 men trust keeps for
their hair loss prevention medication so
if you are ready to take action prevent
hair loss go to keeps.com new rockstars
or click the link in the description to
receive 50 off your first order that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash new rockstars
now since the first trailer for morbius
came out in january 2020 you remember 20
years ago that showed spider-man
graffiti and a cameo by michael keaton
as adrian toombs vulture from spider-man
homecoming in the mcu and he also shows
up in this trailer it's just kind of
hard to tell what universe exactly this
is all supposed to be set in but this
trailer ends with morbius transforming
his face briefly into a monstrous snarl
and then he claims to be venom which
would mean that this is the universe
that venom and venom let there be
carnage with tom hardy eddie brock are
all set in at least before the let there
be carnage post credits same teleports
venom to the mcu who knows what happens
to that world afterward another bit of
evidence here is there's a shot of a
daily bugle newspaper and it's got the
same masthead design from the sam raimi
spiderman movies which is also the case
in venom let there be carnage but there
is some weird stuff going on with this
newspaper it looks like it reads dr
michael morbius apprehended for quote
vampire murder in quote i gotta say this
maybe that's just my journalism degree
talking here this is a horribly written
headline like did morbius murder a
vampire or was it a vampire style
slaying i don't care if it was a quote
it's still unclear also full name and
title in the headline on the front page
full spread across all six columns
whoever this editor was fire him even if
he has a heart condition and yeah
there's some easter eggs here i'll
definitely get more into this in the
breakdown because the rhino on the loose
zoo hoax fools us all in black cat
friend or foe referring of course to the
spider-man adjacent villains rhino and
black cat also apparently in this
universe and then on the far left
finding the truth within told in his own
words another horribly written headline
like who are we talking about there i
don't know maybe it's a nod to peter
parker finding his truth within i don't
know whatever i'm gonna go more into
this in the breakdown but the trailer
also opens with the oscorp building in
the skyline and another tower in
construction beside it now oscorp tower
the headquarters of oscorp of norman
osborne the green goblin this was last
seen in 2014 to the amazing spider-man 2
but it was a different building
suggesting that this is definitely a
different universe than the mark webb
films we have been waiting to see ozcorp
towers show up in the mcu some are
believing it's what avengers tower is
being constructed into i personally
think it's going to be the fantastic
four's baxter building just because i
don't know how long marvel thinks
they're gonna be able to get sony
properties in their universe but i am
more interested in the second building
that's under construction next to it
like is it suggesting that oscorp is
expanding that could be the reason why
there's a rhino in this universe maybe
how they're gonna justify how we have a
black cat and craving the hunter and all
these other spider villains in the
universe with some kind of corporate
backing but also earlier in the trailer
we see another building with horizon on
it that's gotta be a reference to
horizon labs that's a place where peter
parker builds his spider armor in the
comics eventually leading to the tech of
the alcomax corporation which is how we
get spider-man 2099 it just seems like
in general in this movie as compared to
venom or betting them let there be
carnage sony is really reaching a lot of
different directions with various
intentional easter eggs to try to imply
an expanding spider-verse does that mean
morbius is going to show up in
spider-man no way home i highly doubt it
but i think this trailer is a way of
saying look folks after you see
spider-man no way home don't worry we
got some plans for how we're gonna
expand our spumsy and everyone's like
what's the spom see and they're like
we'll work on the name but we got plans
but we gotta talk about the music here
this is the doors people are strange a
song conceived by the door's front man
jim morrison and bobby krieger this was
uh supposedly after jim morrison would
go walking alone through laurel canyon
in los angeles back in 1967. i could see
laurel caney right outside my window it
was just on the other side of the forest
fire smoke in the smog but i i mean i
love the doors more since haunting voice
it is a pretty natural fit for this
movie's gothic aesthetic reflects the
isolation morbius feels from the rest of
society but i like any song that forces
you to think more than a second about it
because the line faces look ugly when
you're alone that was morrison's way of
saying when you're alone and you don't
actually see any faces around you
keeping you company that idea of other
people can just seem really ugly to you
but of course the irony of the song is
that the people aren't strange you are
and that's something jim morrison was
totally aware of when he wrote this
music i don't know he's probably on lsd
when he wrote it but that's when it
opens your mind to really speak the
truth a truth that he was like
melodically basing on the old school 30s
cabaret style music
life is the cabaret
this song repeats the word strange when
you're strange when you're strange i
mean we gotta talk about this folks
because is it not for the actions of
strange that all these worlds are
colliding and everything is so confusing
in fact another eccentric new york
medical doctor of course michael keaton
as adrian toombs returns in this film
and here he tells morbius you and i
should stay in touch and in this moment
it looks like they're like passing each
other as both are in police custody i
mean i don't know folks to me this
suggests that whatever multiverse
collision from spider-man no way home
has already happened at this point of
the story and that morbius could be
taking place on the other side of that
like after the universes have merged but
then again morbius was originally
scheduled to come out in august of 2020
before spider-man no way home which
originally had the release date of july
2021 so maybe they were gonna like tease
that by having an unexplained cameo of
michael keaton a character from the mcu
i mean ultimately to be honest i don't
expect morbius to have much of a good
explanation for how they're in the same
universe they will probably just hope we
don't think too hard about it and hope
that we just see all of this says oh all
these marvel characters are in one
universe it's not really clearly defined
they just happen to have not crossed
past yet and some of them have no idea
what the blip was somehow because i
think that was the implication of the
spider-man graffiti shot that's once
again in this trailer in this particular
graffiti of spider-man is the sam rainey
era design that was on the loading
screen of the ps4 game i mean i don't
know maybe this morbius universe is
taking place in the future of the token
maguire universe and that future just
happens to have a criminal that looks
like a popular mcu villain it is also
conceivable folks that morbius could
just exist in the universe that has a
venom and that has a spider-man and the
daily bugle and a rhino in a black cat
and a michael keaton vulture and is
still its own universe just separate
from all the other ones that we've seen
that are some of those details like the
coincidental convenient overlap that is
in the shape of michael keaton now in
another video that sony released
yesterday jared leto used the term web
possibility which when you look at him
saying that it just seems too on the
nose it's almost like a sony producer
was coaching him to say that in that
promo just to get fans like us excited
to see this movie for the chance that
spider-man might pop up in photos and
newsreel footage like he did in venom
like there'd be carnage it's just so
transparent i mean hey maybe there's an
audience out there who doesn't need
connections to spider-man to enjoy this
vampire movie because yeah we are
getting some cool looking supernatural
vampire action a creepy demonic face
smokey death eater teleportation that
sometimes goes in slow motion all these
swarms of bats but in this case the
struggle i'm having is that you know at
least with venom the vfx and character
design was pretty cool to watch but i'm
not really sold yet on jared leto as
this buff vampire and that's coming from
someone who loves vampire mythology it's
like we're throwing that all out the
window and just making science the
source of the vampiric elements it's
like taking all the things i like about
science and all the things i love about
vampire supernatural mythology and
merging them while leaving the cool
parts of both those things out of the
picture at the end of the day i think we
can all agree is anyone interested in
anything else about this film other than
the insights it's going to give us into
sony's general mindset for what they're
doing with their other movies i don't
know it might be too hard on this let me
know what you think about this trailer
in the comments below i'm hoping i am
proven wrong you can support new
rockstars by checking out our merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com follow
me on instagram and twitter eavos follow
new rockstars and subscribe for
breakdowns of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you